republican lawmakers hosting a
roundtable to demand accountability from
the biden administration as the border
crisis spirals out of control
it's a crisis that didn't have to happen
this is a self-inflicted wound
and as i said repeatedly as vice
president harris went down to central
america in search of the root cause
she really had no further to go then
into the oval office
look at the president united states and
realize
president biden is the root cause of
this crisis we now have a president the
first president in my lifetime that came
into office
and intentionally unsecured the border
this is uh dhs confirms there has been
1.7 million apprehensions on the border
this year alone and keep in mind they
had a secure border how much worse it
would have been had they had president
trump not started the year off as
president retired acting ice director
tom holman attended the round table you
just saw him and talked about that but
with just republicans it's kind of the
non-hearing hearing
tom were they all ears yesterday was
anything accomplished yesterday
yeah a lot was accomplished the senators
that were there took a lot of notes they
asked a lot of questions a lot of good
questions so they left there knowing
what the what the ground looked like
they know what caused this surge and
they know how to fix it they knows what
changes the the changes that my
administration made that caused the
surge so it was it was a good hearing
very informative right chris magnus is
going to take over border patrol rodney
scott was asked to leave essentially
is he going to do a good job because on
the surface he seems the antithesis of
someone that will secure the border
judging by his track record and not even
admitting that it's a crisis
exactly look at that hearing i was
disappointed in hearing i thought he
should have got hammered more if that
would have been a trump nominee they
would have been all over him but look
he's he's a pro sanctuary cities he
refused to work with ice when he's the
chief in tucson and i was a director he
refused to work with our special agents
and officers and even though his
officers wanted to and they tried to
behind the scenes he ordered them not to
assist immigration authorities and look
he he is he's won against president
trump from day one he says his policies
inhumane and bottom line is he fails to
recognize that president trump created
the most secure border
in my lifetime and he is he's a perfect
choice for this administration this
administration wants open borders he's
the worst choice for the men and women
cbp who simply want to do their job and
secure the border
do you think there's any democrats that
understand this is national security and
south party politics gary peters is the
chairman of oversight he's going to get
these notes that you guys gave him how
to secure the border he's got the
president's got 23 approval on border
security why wouldn't it be in his own
political interest to get a hold of this
thing
i think it absolutely absolutely is look
the numbers right now are historic high
historic we've never seen numbers like
this in the history of county numbers
with the border patrol if he cares about
his political future if he cares about
the safety and security of this country
he should have hearing because this is
more this isn't just about illegal
immigration this is about public safety
it's about public health it's about it's
a national security issue look border
patrol all arrested 17 people on an fbi
watch list
400 000 got aways how many of them were
known as respected terrorists if you
think that number zero then
you are you certainly don't understand
the dynamics of the border and not many
people like you think they actually
turned around 60 of the 1.7 million uh
especially when we're seeing these
overnight flights uh and we need night
vision glasses to see everybody there
dropping off in small airports around
the country
tom hopefully someone will start
listening to you thanks so much for
joining us